الكثير منا يمشي حافي القدمين في المنزل
بحكم العاده لكن هل تعلم عزيزي المشاهد
ويعادل ان هناك يوم عالمي للسير حافي
القدمين اسمه
كل سنه اول يوم من يونيو يتم تشجيع الناس
على ترك احذيتهم والسماح لاقدامهم بالتنفس
يعني باختصار هناك شيء من الشفاء في
المشيء من دون حذاء بالفعل دراسات جديده
اوضحت فوائد صحيه غير متوقعه للمشي من دون
حذاء رابطه اخصائيه لعلاج الطبيعي في
المانيا
باقدام حافيه يوميا يساهم في وقايه
الانسان من الاصابه بتشوهات القدم دراسه
اخرى يا راويه اجرها اطباء متخصصون في
الطب الرياضي اظهرت ان المشي باقدام حافيه
يعزز النمو البدني والدماغ عند الاطفال
حتى التخلص ايضا من القلق والتوتر والارق
كلها فوائد من المشي من دون حذاء
[موسيقى]